James Corden is almost as famous as baby
he may take issue with that he made
another British not a sorcerer but he is
taking the Late Late Show on the road
for a star-studded week of shows in his
hometown of London it will include a
special game of dodgeball team USA
planes team u UK playing that plays team
u.s. led by a captain who is ready to
win at all costs I want you to know that
I am proud of each and every one of you
strength is not measured on how you
throw the ball it is measured in here
when they go low we also go low because
that's how dodgeball works am i right we
also go I love that the dodgeball game
between cordons team and UK and Michelle
Obama's team u.s. will air tonight James
Corden is with us from his set in London
James good morning how are you good
morning
it's good afternoon here but good
morning to you I'm very well know you we
are well thank you so we have to know
how on earth did you convince the former
First Lady of the United States to play
a game of dodgeball well it's the
strangest thing because the the former
first lady got in touch with our show
and said is there any way we could do
something fun I'd love to film something
I'm gonna be in Los Angeles and you know
it took us sort of less than 0.4 seconds
to go yes we'd love to do that and it's
been a couple of years since we did that
carpool karaoke together and we started
thinking well what would be a good and
fun thing to do and we sort of came up
with maybe we could do a United Kingdom
versus us a game of dodgeball and we
called around some friends of the show
and and put together something I mean
it's so it's so gloriously stupid and we
really have people that enjoy it tonight
you know you've got two great teams
you've got UIC Melissa McCarthy is is on
the first lady's team you've got
Benedict Cumberbatch on your team who
else
Harry Styles Allison Janney Mila Kunis
Lena weaith yeah the list goes on and on
yeah it's it's gonna be a it's a fun one
that's for sure I hope no one was
injured in this game only only only one
nation's prized dodge ball was the real
winner that's the truth
you know this is the third time you've
been back to London to host the Late
Late Show what do you enjoy about going
home what do you what sights you take in
well it's it's really nice obviously for
me personally but also we have quite a
few British people work on the show so
to to come home is always a nice thing
it's nice whether it's coming home at
Christmas or coming home in the summer
but to to bring this the show home and
do it in this historic venue of central
hall Westminster and am really kind of
showcase this our show which we are
beyond proud of and beyond proud of how
many people would seem to enjoy watching
it it's a very special thing for us to
come back to to London and and it's
really become a kind of centerpiece of
our year really where we like to kind of
show people this is this is kind of I
guess the truest example of what our
show is you know the other 40 or so
weeks of the year that we're on the air
you know James you also went to Paris on
this trip to film an episode of a new
episode of crosswalk the musical how did
the French take to you performing ladies
habla and on the streets of Paris the
the French the residents of Paris took
to us doing cross all the musical in
Paris exactly how you think they did
however you imagine their reaction to be
that's exactly what it was are you
describing it was amazing you know look
we've we've done that segment in in Los
Angeles in London in New York and to go
to Paris to do ladies rather in front of
the Arc de Triomphe just seemed like the
next the next logical step really it
took a long time to get sort of the
right
permits to to shoot but kind of the most
thrilling thing about it is it kind of
felt like the first time we did it
really because now when we do in Los
Angeles all we've done it in London or
or in New York that segment sort of lots
of people have seen it now so there's
always kind of somebody going oh it's
that thing that I've seen that was not
the case in Paris let me tell you that
right now all right James Corden we will
be reading rooting for dodgeball team
u.s. I'm sorry to say and if England
should play the u.s. women in the
Women's World Cup will also be cheering
for Team USA there we appreciate it
as long as you call it football and
don't call it soccer that's all that
really matters I can't agree to that I'm
sorry sir we gotta go you can watch The
Late Late Show with James Corden in
London tonight through Thursday at 12:37
1137 central that is right after the
Late Show with Stephen Colbert all of it
right here on CBS